Buenos días a todas y a todos.
Ayer conocíamos
finalmente
el acuerdo entre el partido socialista y yunsper
Cataluña para desbloquear la investidura
y llevar a cabo la amnistía
que permita desjudicializar definitivamente
el conflicto entre el estado y Cataluña.
Constatamos así
que existe en este momento
1 mayoría plurinacional y democrática,
aunque no progresista, en el congreso de los diputados
y eso sin duda es 1 Buena noticia para nuestro país.
Sin embargo, no os oculto mi enorme preocupación
por las imágenes que estamos viendo en estos días
en las calles de Madrid.
Respeto profundamente que la ciudadanía de nuestro país,
piense lo que piense,
se manifieste pacíficamente.
El problema es que lo que estamos viendo es otra cosa.
Lo que estamos viendo estos días
es el recrudecimiento de 1 estrategia golpista
que la derecha política,
mediática y judicial
lleva mucho tiempo desplegando en nuestro país.
Las manifestaciones frente a sedes socialistas
y frente al congreso
están llenas de agresividad,
de violencia, de discursos y proclamas de odio
con numerosas personas de ideología neonazi
y ostentación de símbolos preconstitucionales,
y en ellas se dan cita
desde el comando parapolicial de desocupa
hasta panfletos comunicativos
que llevan años alentando
el golpismo contra 1 gobierno legítimamente elegido.
Y sin embargo,
estas movilizaciones son solo la punta del iceberg.
Recordemos cómo durante estos años
se ha permitido que los sectores reaccionarios
controlen el consejo general del poder judicial,
el máximo órgano de gobierno de los jueces,
con el mandato caducado e incumpliendo
La Constitución española
sin que nadie hiciera nada
y a pesar de contar con mayoría en el congreso.
Para evitarlo
se permitió que el sector conservador
del Tribunal Constitucional
diera 1 golpe judicial al poder legislativo
impidiendo 1 votación en el senado,
algo que no tiene precedentes
en la democracia de nuestro país.
Se permitió que los panfletos ultraderechistas
camparan a sus anchas
en el Congreso.
Se ha permitido que
en la misma Radiotelevisión española
y en todas las demás televisiones,
pero particularmente en la pública,
se mienta sobre 1 fuerza política en el gobierno
como es podemos
y se extiendan bulos permanentemente sobre nosotras.
Hoy todos
nos solidarizamos
con los ataques a las sedes del partido socialista
y está muy bien hacerlo.
Es lo que tenemos que hacer.
¿Pero dónde estaba el partido socialista
y la progresiva mediática
cuando se acosaba a 1 vicepresidente
y a 1 ministra del gobierno de España
en su casa casa en la que viven 3 niños pequeños?
Hace mucho tiempo
que teníamos que haber empezado
a frenar la estrategia golpista de la derecha,
especialmente
cuando contábamos con 1 mayoría absoluta
en el congreso de los diputados.
Esperamos que no sea demasiado tarde.
La estrategia de no decir nada porque a mí no me pasa,
es peligrosa y termina pasando factura.
Lo que estamos viendo es peligroso,
pero no para nosotras o para el partido socialista.
Es 1 peligro para la democracia
y especialmente para los colectivos
que siempre están en el punto de Mira
de los discursos de odio y de la violencia,
las mujeres, las personas LGTBI,
las personas migrantes irracializadas,
quienes piensan como nosotros
y se atreven a decirlo en alto.
Esas personas hoy se sienten más inseguras en España
y eso es enormemente preocupante.
Lamentablemente,
tengo que decir
que el partido socialista
ha decidido comenzar esta legislatura
con muy mal pie.
Para hacer frente a estas derechas es fundamental,
fundamental, que el bloque democrático tenga,
en primer lugar, conciencia de bloque.
Y sin embargo,
solo podemos
está pensando más allá de sus intereses partidistas.
Todo el Mundo sabe que el partido socialista
no hace la amnistía
por convicción,
sino por obligación,
igual que tuvo que aprobar la ley de vivienda,
las leyes feministas,
¿el tope al gas o la rebaja del transporte público
porque
podemos tenía la fuerza suficiente para exigírselo?
Necesitamos más altura de miras.
Necesitamos que todos los partidos
del bloque democrático
entiendan que nos jugamos muchísimo
y que todos somos necesarios,
especialmente el motor podemos,
que ha demostrado en estos años
ser quien aporta valentía
y la capacidad de transformación necesarias.
O es que alguien piensa
que las mujeres habrían sentido interpeladas
a salir a votar en masa
contra las derechas
si no fuera
porque Han sentido que el gobierno de coalición
también ha peleado por ellas
en este contexto tan adverso.
Creo que es mi responsabilidad como secretaria general
deciros básicamente la verdad,
se Han cumplido 3 meses
desde que se celebraron las elecciones generales
del 23 j ese día,
Gracias a la movilización masiva
de la gente progresista de nuestro país
y Gracias a que en el plano interno
podemos hizo 1 ejercicio de responsabilidad
sin precedentes en la política española,
logramos todas juntas
frenar democráticamente a las derechas.
En todo este tiempo,
el partido socialista ha sido completamente incapaz
de algo tan básico,
tan básico, tan de mínimo respeto entre socios,
como es
responder a las 5 propuestas que podemos ha hecho
para lograr 1 gobierno valiente y estable,
1 gobierno que se tome en serio la próxima legislatura
y que siga profundizando de verdad
las transformaciones sociales,
feministas y democráticas
que tanto necesita nuestro país.
El partido socialista y el Presidente Sánchez
parecen completamente determinados
a conformar 1 gobierno en el que solo manden ellos,
en el que impongan todas las decisiones.
Lamento informaros de que en este momento
prácticamente ninguna de las peticiones de podemos
ha sido atendida
y que dado que no existe
ningún acuerdo programático o de gobierno
entre el partido socialista y podemos,
en este momento
debo someter a las bases de podemos,
las que de verdad mandan en esta organización,
la decisión de si apoyar o no
exclusivamente la investidura de Pedro Sánchez.
En mi opinión, a pesar de todo,
nuestro voto tiene que ser sí,
principalmente
para respetar el mandato de la ciudadanía progresista.
23 de Julio que dijo alto y claro
que no quería que gobernaran las derechas,
pero no os oculto que estoy enormemente preocupada
Por el rumbo con el que el partido socialista
arranca esta nueva legislatura,
el Zoe está siendo enormemente irresponsable,
renunciando a contar con podemos
en la construcción del bloque
plurinacional y democrático.
Hoy quiero recordarles a los socialistas
que la gente les votó
para algo más que para hacer amnistías,
por muy necesarias que estas Sean.
Y esta sin duda lo es.
Pero la gente está esperando
que hagamos algo
con el precio del alquiler de los alimentos,
que droguemos la ley mordaza y, sobre todo,
que sigamos avanzando en políticas feministas valientes.
El partido socialista se equivoca
despreciando al motor podemos,
porque podemos ha sido la fuerza
que ha planteado las medidas
más ambiciosas de esta legislatura
y más importante que eso,
que ha logrado con su persistencia y su convicción,
que esas medidas se hagan realidad.
Para liderar no basta imponer,
hace falta convencer.
Para enfrentar a estas derechas.
Tenemos que seguir avanzando en derechos
para enfrentar a esas derechas golpistas.
Como estamos viendo estos días.
No basta con 1 gobierno en el que solo mandelsoe,
hace falta 1 gobierno valiente con podemos.
Podemos, si así lo deciden los inscritos y las inscritas,
VA a poner 1 vez más
por delante de sus intereses como partido
los intereses de la gente de nuestro país,
como ya hicimos en 2018,
dando gratis nuestros votos al partido socialista
para sacar a Mariano Rajoy de la Moncloa,
como hicimos en 2 019 cuando Pablo Iglesias
Dio 1 Paso a 1 lado
para Dejar al partido socialista
sin excusas
que impidieran el primer gobierno de coalición
de nuestra democracia reciente
y también,
como hicimos en el acuerdo preelectoral, consumar
para garantizar aquello en lo que ni Sánchez
ni Díaz creían,
la repetición del gobierno de coalición.
El problema
es que por mucha responsabilidad que tenga podemos,
si el partido socialista persiste en sus errores,
las derechas acabarán pasando.
Muchas Gracias